[Music]
in our last video
we have seen that the direction angles
of a vector
passing through the origin are the
angles that it makes with the positive
x y and z axis now
what about a vector which does not pass
through the origin
what will be its direction angles
let's call this vector vector b
for this vector you can imagine three
lines parallel to three coordinate axes
intersecting at the initial point of the
vector
the angles that the vector makes with
them will be its direction angles
moreover if we draw a vector parallel to
the vector b
passing through the origin and in the
same direction
then the set of direction angles of this
vector
will be the same as vector b because
they both are pointing
in the same direction in fact
all of the vectors parallel to vector b
and in the same direction
will have the same direction angles
now let's go back to the earlier example
of the vector
passing through the origin it has the
following direction angles
now consider a line in three dimensions
coinciding with this vector
now obviously a line and a vector are
two different things
a line extends infinitely on both sides
and has
no unique direction whereas a vector is
an arrow of finite length
pointing in a specific direction
what will be the direction angles of
this line
a line extends in two opposite
directions
so it will have two sets of direction
angles
one set will be the same as this vector
along the line
pointing that way and the other set will
be the direction angles of
any other vector pointing in the
opposite direction
but what is this other set of direction
angles
both sets of direction angles are
related
observe that if this angle is 60 degrees
then this angle made by the line in the
opposite direction
with the positive x-axis is 180 degrees
minus 60 degrees similarly
these two angles are 180 degrees minus
120 degrees and 180 degrees
minus 45 degrees
so this is the second set of direction
angles of this line
we can denote them by alpha dash beta
dash
and gamma dash we will also want them to
be in the range between
0 and pi including 0 and pi
and again the other lines in this 3d
space
parallel to this line will have the same
two sets of direction angles
normally when we talk about direction
angles of a line
we want to work with any one of the two
sets
so it's important that when we are
provided with a set of direction angles
for a line
we know that they are for which
direction of the line
and with this we end our video
next we'll be talking about the
direction cosines
and see how to calculate direction
cosines of a given
vector so see you in the next video